die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den sport guten ernte von mir und
das sind die nachrichten themen von
heute
erschütternde zahl aus mario pohl nach
ukrainischen angaben wurden alleine dort
mindestens 5000 todesopfer beerdigt
nur rote ministerien in saarbrücken die
spd holt mit anke rehlinger die absolute
mehrheit und kann künftig das saarland
allein regieren
und goldene statuen und eine ohrfeige
bei der oscar verleihung in hollywood
überrascht ein wutanfall von bussen die
[Musik]
zerstörung nach 33 tagen des kriegs ist
gewaltig neben den tausenden toten und
verletzten spricht die ukrainische
regierung von schäden in höhe von fast
500 65 milliarden dollar morgen soll in
der türkei neu verhandelt werden heute
melden wieder beide seiten militärische
erfolge gegen kiel und julia schröter
aus technischen gründen vorübergehend
geschlossen das schild gehört zu einer
ehemaligen tankstelle mit kaffee und
stollen anker westlich von kiew die
kämpfe wüteten hier wochenlang übrig
blieb eine geisterstadt die letzten
russischen scharfschützen seien
vertrieben berichtete das ukrainische
militär selbstbewusst
jetzt kommen sie auch nicht mehr mit den
hubschraubern
sie bauen jetzt verteidigungsstellungen
viele von ihnen sind tot
tatsächlich scheint der versuch der
russen kiew 1 zu kreisen vorerst
gescheitert
auch aus bischof sollen sich die
invasoren zurückgezogen haben kaum sind
die kämpfe abgeflaut kehren viele
bewohner zurück gefährlich bleiben aber
raketenangriffe die regierung in kiew
spricht von einer unmenschlichen taktik
in beschäftigt der kindergarten in
trümmern
ich wünsche mir dass alles geregelt wird
dass frieden herrscht und freundschaft
es ist schlimm dass vor allem die kinder
leiden es sind schon so viele gestorben
und das bekommen die zuschauer des
russischen staatsfernsehens heute
gezeigt raketen die feindliche flugzeuge
abschießen und die eigenen truppen die
professionell vorrücken um den plan zu
vollenden im süden gehört dazu wohl auch
die eroberung von mario pohl der letzten
bastion unter der kontrolle der ukraine
sie melden 160 tausend menschen
eingeschlossen 5000 getötet immer wieder
versuchen autokonvois rauszukommen eine
wilde lebensgefährliche flucht ludmilla
und der mann haben es geschafft im
kugelhagel ihre heimatstadt so berichten
sie das seien nur noch ruinen und tote
menschen auf den straßen
ein ehemaliger supermarkt 230 kilometer
nördlich von mario pohl ist das ziel der
flucht hier gibt es erste hilfe und das
gefühl zumindest vorerst in sicherheit
zu sein
morgen hat die diplomatie wieder eine
chance nicht nur die menschen in
mariupol warten auf ein ende der gewalt
fragen wir jörg brase inländer gibt es
irgendwelche anzeichen dass ich bei den
verhandlungen morgen etwas bewegen
könnte
also ich mache mir da keine großen
hoffnungen auch der ukrainische
aussenminister sagte heute noch mal dass
es bei den wesentlichen punkten
überhaupt keine annäherung gebe er
nannte als beispiel einen sofortigen
waffenstillstand und den abzug der
russischen truppen da sei überhaupt kein
entgegenkommen der russischen seite zu
erkennen sagte er auch nicht was den
politischen status der krim oder des
donners der don was region angeht das
heißt von einem treffen auf
ministerebene oder gar der
staatspräsidenten wo man dann wirklich
entscheidungen treffen könnte sind wir
wohl immer noch meilenweit entfernt
morgen in istanbul trifft man sich ja
wieder auf arbeitsebene wo man schon
seit wochen miteinander verhandelt und
ich denke das wäre da schon ein großer
erfolg weil man sich auf einen echten
humanitären korridor aus der stadt
mariupol einigen könnte der
bürgermeister hat heute gefordert dass
auch noch die letzten zivilisten aus der
stadt evakuiert werden die offenbar kurz
vor dem fall also kurz vor der einnahme
durch russische truppen steht ein gewinn
für diese einschätzung live aus lembeck
war dass jörg brase
fast vier millionen ukrainer haben auf
der flucht vor dem krieg bereits ihr
land verlassen die hälfte davon sind in
polen untergekommen etwa 300.000 in
deutschland bei der weiteren verteilung
der geflüchteten setzen die
innenminister der eu auf freiwillige
aufnahme auch bundesinnenministerium
faeser sprach sich in brüssel gegen eine
verpflichtende quote aus geplant ist
eine finanzielle unterstützung der eu
länder die menschen aufnehmen
innerhalb der ukraine sind sogar noch
mehr menschen auf der flucht etwa
6,5 millionen haben ihre häuser und
wohnungen verlassen
jörg brase zeigt wie in lemberg
hilfsorganisationen versuchen die
geflüchteten so gut wie möglich zu
versorgen
das kleider lager der caritas liegt
verborgen in einem hinterhof in der
innenstadt von viiv dem ehemaligen
lemberg olena sucht kleidung und
spielzeug für ihre kinder sie kommen aus
grammer tomsk in der ost ukraine heute
von russischen truppen besetzt wir
konnten sie nicht mitnehmen auf ihrer
flucht in lemberg bleiben wollen sie
nicht länger als nötig
keiner weiß wie es jetzt weitergeht wir
wollen dass das alles so schnell wie
möglich endet wir wollen wieder nach
hause wir wollen unsere ganze ukraine
ein privatunternehmer stellte seinen
neubau zur verfügung als lagerhalle
private spenden werden hier gelagert und
an die flüchtlinge in der stadt verteilt
eine unserer hauptaufgaben als lokale
caritas station wie hier in rif ist es
ein logistikzentrum aufzubauen
wir müssen viele waren vorhalten denn
wir endlich und in der ganzen region
erwarten bald eine dritte
flüchtlingswelle aus den belagerten
gebieten im
knapp 200 menschen versorgen sie in
einem wohnheim jeden tag mit frischem
essen entwurzelte aus allen teilen der
ukraine
victoria floh mit ihrer familie aus dem
umkämpften kharkiv im osten
es wurde geschossen überall wurde
geschossen alles ist zerstört das
stadtzentrum liegt in trümmern wir haben
es geschafft rauszukommen gott sei dank
nein sie wollen nicht dass wir sie und
ihre familie in ihrem zimmer filmen sagt
victoria sie sei dankbar für die
unterstützung aber sei ihnen peinlich
nun so leben zu müssen und auf fremde
hilfe angewiesen zu sein
die not ist groß aber auch die
spendenbereitschaft ist enorm
126 millionen euro sind bereits für das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
zusammengekommen zu dem auch die caritas
gehört wenn auch sie den menschen helfen
wollen hier noch mal die infos die bahn
de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100 stichwort
zdf nothilfe ukraine alle infos auch
unter spenden punkt zdf.de oder im zdf
text auf seite 8 190
die gruppe der sieben führenden
wirtschaftsmächte hat russischen
forderungen nach einer begleichung von
gasrechnungen in rubel eine absage
erteilt das sagte
bundeswirtschaftsminister habeck nach
einer besprechung der g7 energieminister
die ankündigung von russlands präsident
putin sei ein klarer bruch der
bestehenden verträge so habeck
in russland ist eine der letzten stimmen
der opposition verstummt die unabhängige
zeitung nowaja gaseta die redaktion gab
bekannt ihre arbeit bis zum ende der so
wörtlich russischen militär operation in
der ukraine einzustellen bereits zweimal
hat die medienaufsicht das blatt
verwahren es droht der lizenzentzug
die nowaja gaseta hat großes
internationales renomee im vergangenen
jahr bekam chefredakteur murat auf den
friedensnobelpreis
nach berlin dort drehte sich heute in
den parteizentralen alles um das
wahlergebnis an der saar die spd feiert
ihre absolute mehrheit als signal für
die kommenden landtagswahlen die cdu
deutlich ab jetzt will genau diesen
trend nicht erkennen winnie heescher
über zerknirschte verlierer und eine
strahlende siegerin
alle augen auf anke rehlinger 45 jahre
alte juristin und nächste
ministerpräsidentin des saarlandes sie
hat die absolute mehrheit der mandate
errungen und macht auch ziemlich schnell
schnörkellos klar dass sie an der sagt
allein regieren will wenn es ganz knapp
würde noch mal mit den mandaten muss man
sicherlich zu allen gesprächen bereit
seien aber moment gehe ich davon aus
dass wir uns ans werk machen eine
alleinregierung im saarland auf den weg
zu bringen ihr ergebnis macht es der spd
heute leicht sich selbst zu loben und
anderen einen mitzugeben anders als
andere parteien konnten wir von berlin
aus mit rückenwind denen die gesamte spd
familie aus bund und ländern war im
wahlkampf unterwegs sind hat die saar
spd unterstützt in der cdu hatten sie an
einem sieg schon vor dem wahltag nicht
geglaubt daraus macht friedrich merz
keinen hehl jetzt heißt es niederlage
kleinreden brand 9 15 wir hätten uns
gewünscht dass wir den auftakt der
landtagswahlen in diesem jahr besser
hinbekommen als am gestrigen tag im
saarland aber dies ist nach unserer
festen überzeugung und einschätzung kein
präjudiz für die landtagswahlen die in
diesem jahr noch stattfinden
tobias hans war nicht nach berlin
angereist das ist natürlich auch ein
bitterer tag für mich persönlich da
diese wahlniederlage natürlich auch mit
meiner person verbunden ist und deswegen
übernehme ich auch die verantwortung für
dieses ergebnis und dann warten jetzt
sie die zentrale nicht mehr gesehen
politisches ende durch technisches ko
sein rücktritt wird erwartet
schauen wir auf das genaue wahlergebnis
da zeigt sich neben dem duell der großen
wie knapp es bei den kleinen wurde die
spd kommt auf
43,5 prozent die cdu auf
28,5 als einzige weitere partei schafft
es die afg in den landtag mit 5,7
prozent hauchdünn raus die grünen 4,9
nicht drin auch die fdp 4,8 und die
linke erlebt einen absturz auf
2,6 prozent
dabei war das saarland einst eine
hochburg der linken besonders bitter ist
das ergebnis auch für die grünen ihnen
fehlten gerade mal 23 stimmen britta
buchholz
welches signal geht von dieser wahl aus
die grünen jedenfalls regieren nun in
berlin aber wer sich davon rückenwind
erwartet hatte wurde enttäuscht
das ist natürlich für uns alle ein
bitteres ergebnis wir hätten uns sehr
gewünscht in den landtag einzuziehen so
in allen 16 ländern vertreten zu sein
die fdp zieht zum dritten mal in folge
nicht im saarland ein zweckoptimismus
von parteichef man sei nahe dran gewesen
an der politik der fdp in berlin habe es
nicht gelegen es ist eine wahl an der
saar gewesen die sehr eigene gesetze
hatte stark geprägt durch die
auseinandersetzungen zwischen einem
ministerpräsidenten und seiner
herausforderin die ja vorher schon auch
seine stellvertreterin gewesen ist
darunter haben alle kleineren parteien
gelitten besonders gelitten hat die
linke erst verließ oskar lafontaine die
partei und nun auch der wähler 2,6
prozent ein katastrophales ergebnis die
beiden parteichefinnen sind frustriert
[Musik]
fühlen uns relativ hoch aber
wir haben uns im september entschieden
dass wir die verantwortung übernehmen
und die weiterentwicklung der partei die
linke auf den weg bringen so da sind wir
jetzt mittendrin die wahlanalyse der afg
ohne afd parteichef copala der kamen
nicht in die bundespressekonferenz ihm
fehlte ein gültiger zweig nachweis in
den saarländer landtag kamen die partei
wenn auch nur knapp auf jeden fall liegt
es daran dass wir uns allerdings eine
gewisse streitigkeit haben sie wissen
also landes festgenommen worden von vier
personen das hatte auswirkungen leicht
drei kleine parteien können sich nicht
über die fünf-prozent-hürde retten
unklar welches signal diese wahl für die
weiteren landtagswahlen aussendet
kommen wir zur corona lage und der
diskussion mit welchen maßnahmen es
künftig weitergehen soll
aktuell stabilisieren sich die zahlen
auf hohem niveau die inzidenz liegt bei
1700 trotzdem laufen ende der woche die
maßnahmen aus viele lassen sich nur in
sogenannten hot spots fortführen
beispielsweise eine masken pflicht im
öffentlichen raum doch wann ist eine
region ein hotspot darüber gibt es
unterschiedliche vorstellungen hagen
nicolas das harz klinikum in quedlinburg
auf der station für hautkrankheiten
verwalten sie derzeit den mangel wie in
der gesamten klinik fehlt ein drittel
des personals allein im märz war jeder
zehnte beschäftigte an corona erkrankt
mit gravierenden folgen mehr stress
höhere belastung auf alle fälle es führt
aber auch dazu dass wir geplante
operationen absagen müssen auch zum teil
dringlich ich denke da besonders an die
krebsoperation in sachsen anhalt liegt
die sieben tage incidents bei über 2000
zum sogenannten hotspot will man sich
hier dennoch nicht erklären und plant
die korona schutzmaßnahmen nach dem
zweiten april nicht fortzuführen anders
mecklenburg vorpommern das beschloss per
hotspot regel die korona maßnahmen bis
ende april zu verlängern hamburg plant
ähnliches angesichts der uneinheitlichen
regeln appelliert
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach an die bundesländer von der
hotspot regel gebrauch zu machen denn
eine deutschlandweit einheitliche regel
sei rechtlich nicht möglich und ich sehe
selbst auch viele städte und landkreise
wo eine solche hot spot regelung jetzt
genutzt werden können somit haben wir
aus meiner sicht ein gutes gesetz was zu
wenig genutzt wird schwellenwerte ab
wann eine region hot spot ist sind darin
nicht definiert ob personalausfälle in
kliniken operationen die abgesagt werden
müssen oder der ausfall der krankenhaus
notversorgung maßstäbe sein können das
müssten die länder definieren im harz
klinikum quedlinburg hofft man auf eine
baldige regelung pauschale lockerungen
glaubt man hier seien in der aktuellen
situation der falsche schritt
0 witt das ist die strategie chinas und
weil die zahlen in shanghai steigen
müssen jetzt alle 26 millionen einwohner
in den lockdown brücken und tunnel sind
geschlossen bis freitag wird eine hälfte
der stadt dicht gemacht dann ist die
andere hälfte dran dazu massentests der
bevölkerung gestern wurden 3.500 neue
corona fälle in shanghai registriert
mehr als 50 prozent aller neuinfektionen
in ganz china
und jetzt zu einem abend in hollywood
der von glamour bis eklat alles zu
bieten hatte bei der oscar verleihung
gab es strahlende gesichter eine
ohrfeige modische hingucker und dazu
noch deutsche gewinner der komponist
hans zimmer und der effekt experte
gärten fc bekamen beide achtung ihren
jeweils zweiten oscar beide für das
science fiction epos tune alles in allem
eine ziemlich bewegte veranstaltung
claudia bates
zurück zu altem glanz wollte man nach
jahren des verbrechens und der kritik
ein gestrafftes programm mehr diversität
diese oscars werden in die
filmgeschichte eingehen allerdings nicht
wegen der filmkunst komiker chris rock
scherzt über die raspelkurzen haaren von
jada pinkett smith nicht witzig wenn sie
leidet an krankhaftem haarausfall ihr
mann superstar will smith verliert die
fassung und schlug zu
wow
als ausgerechnet er dann den preis als
bester schauspieler erhält tränenreiche
erklärung
ich möchte mich bei der akademie und den
anderen nominierten entschuldigen liebe
lässt einen verrückte dinge tun
jessica chastain ist beste
schauspielerin und jane campion beste
regisseurin für den eindringlichen
western the power of the dome
okay
anrührend geht es im besten film zug
oder
die 17-jährige ruby ist tochter
gehörloser eltern als die sängerin
werden will stürzt das die familie in
nöte
ich möchte der akademie dafür danken
dass sie anerkennung zeigt für einen
film über liebe und familie in dieser
schwierigen zeit wie für brot vor allem
in der auch die nicht vergessen werden
die gleichzeitig in der ukraine um ihr
land und leben kämpfen
weil ihre würde angesichts der
zerstörung kann man von ihrer
widerstandskraft nur bewirkt sie
bekam zwar standing ovations doch die
akademie stellte hinterher klar dass man
gewalt nicht billige
[Musik]
auch stars sind nur menschen jetzt zum
fußball klassiker der morgen wieder
ansteht niederlande gegen deutschland ja
ein testspiel aber auch der erste
wirkliche härtetest für bundestrainer
hansi flick der nach acht siegen in acht
spielen nun auf einen echten top redner
trifft das dfb-team aber nicht in
topbesetzung wichtige spieler fehlen im
fliegt ihm fehlt seit einer woche josua
kimmig wer täglich auf die geburt seines
dritten kindes wartet mitten in der
heutigen pressekonferenz bekommt fliegt
dann ein signal dass jemand durch
klingelt
super
mal zurück dass ich gleich zurückrufen
ohne kimmig aber mit mut gegen louis van
gaal und oranje wir wollen uns alle auf
das kräftemessen gegen die niederlande
das spiel morgen die erste große prüfung
unter hansi flick
zur formel 1 da hat max verstappen den
großen preis von saudi arabien geworden
der weltmeister lieferte sich mit
ferrari-pilot schale claire ein
spannendes duell verstappen in seinem
red bull fuhr schließlich vier runden
vor schluss entscheidend an die spitze
und siegte mit einer halben sekunde
vorsprung
ja und zum schluss eine traurige
nachricht fast 40 jahre im sport
journalismus 21 jahre im zdf davon zwölf
als sportchef des zweiten dieter
gruschwitz ist im alter von 68 jahren
gestorben
den größten des sports ist er vor und
hinter der kamera begegnet der 1954
geborene gruschwitz war mal dritter bei
den deutschen judo meisterschaften und
blieb auch diesem sport als reporter
erhalten über den sender freies berlin
kam er zum zdf von 2005 bis 2017 als
sportchef 2006 bekam er den deutschen
fernsehpreis für die berichterstattung
von der fußball-wm mythos meyer und
jürgen klopp fand er ein experten du
dass die zuschauer begeisterte auch nach
der leichtathletik wm in berlin 2009
nahm er den deutschen fernsehpreis
entgegen zuletzt gehörte gruschwitz dem
kuratorium der sepp herberger stiftung
an
und dazu war er das sollten sie wissen
ein sehr feiner mensch und ein ganz
besonders warm herziger und engagierter
kollege er wird uns fehlen
das wetter wird diese woche noch mal
deutlich kälter es könnte sogar noch mal
schneien mehr hat gleich katja hornuf
marietta slomka begrüßt sie um viertel
vor zehn im heute journal
wir sagen tschüss und freuen uns wenn
sie morgen wieder dabei sind alles gute
[Musik]
guten abend es ist fast so als hätte
sich die kalte luft von norden mit dem
sahara staub aus süden bei uns
miteinander verabredet das sind die
tiefs ilona und jana und während wir den
saharastaub wohl bis zum ende der woche
loswerden wird sich die kalte luft
mindestens noch bis zum nächsten
wochenende bei uns halten die kaltfront
merken wir auch heute nach denn da kann
es weiterhin ein kleines bisschen
tröpfeln hier in norddeutschland südlich
der donau ist es dagegen klar dort
sinken die temperaturen auf 2 bis 0 grad
sonst bleibt die nacht bei 8 bis 3 grad
milder und richtig kalt bleibt es morgen
in norddeutschland mit dieser kaltfront
da liegen die höchsttemperatur nur so
bei 8 bis 12 grad in der mitte sind es
so 12 bis 15 und im süden 17 bis 21 grad
jedenfalls wenn der saharastaub das
zulässt meist wird er die sonne
verschleiern und spätestens am
nachmittag kommen von südwesten einige
regenwolken auf im norden ist dagegen
diese kaltfront unterwegs und von
schleswig-holstein lockern die wolken
dann nach mir dich auf bei nordwestwind
in den nächsten tagen wird es deutlich
wechselhafter wolkiger und kälter und
selbst im flachland kann es dann zum
freitag etwas schneien guten abend